alors monsieur pichot puis chasse je
suis couché ça voilà le ministère
souhaite que la réorganisation des
services soient confiées à quelqu'un de
plus compétent
non non enfin si tu prends la direction
la zone obscure semaine oui en fait
non
vaincre un peuple un drapeau frappé par
frapper l'esprit vous utilisez dans
votre profession skt mots c'est moche et
du coup aux antilles comme le
reconnaissent plus et pourquoi ça me dit
ils vont laisser les caténaires
connaissent pas il est trop suspect
groupe d'or c'est comme la police quand
il se trompe ça fait des dégâts
soubès médicaux la métaphore sur la
police n'était pas tout à fait innocent